Good evening. No, I'm super low.
It's on, but it's low.
my volume.
Good evening everyone.
Hello. Thank you for being here. I now
call to order this August 12th, 2025
meeting of Lancaster City Council. A
couple of uh reminders for everyone just
here at the top of the meeting. This
meeting and its participants, thank you.
Are being recorded this evening. Please
take a moment to silence your phones and
devices if you haven't done so already.
Uh first, uh a note, Bill Five under
item C on the agenda was not taken up by
the public safety committee last
evening. It was placed on this agenda
due to advertising requirements, but
since it was not advanced to full
council, we will not do a first reading
this evening. During our meeting this
evening, there will be opportunities for
public comment. The first general public
comment period is for residents that
registered in advance to speak about
items that are not on the agenda.
Residents may also comment on individual
items on our legislative agenda, which
is section nine. Finally, a second
public comment period will be at the end
of the agenda for any other speakers
wishing to address council. All speakers
will be please be reminded to begin with
your name and block of residence or
municipality if not in the city for the
meeting record. Be advised that public
comment is not a question and answer
period. All comments are limited to
three minutes per speaker. To help us
keep time this evening, I have the light
in front of me here. It will turn green
when a speaker's time begins. It will
blink yellow when there is one minute
remaining and begin to blink red when
three minutes has been reached. If a
speaker continues past three minutes, I
will ask them to end their comment. I
appreciate everyone's uh cooperation to
maintain equal time and also order
during this meeting. uh speakers
addressing city council, members of the
audience are all expected to conduct
themselves in an orderly manner and
please remain respectful to others. Now,
for all of those who are willing and
able, please rise for the pledge of
allegiance.
>> I pledge algiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for it stands nationy
and justice for all.
Mr. Harris, would you please call the
role of members?
>> Yes, Madam President. Mr. Med
>> here.
>> Mr. Royo
>> Mr. Glee
>> here.
>> Miss Craig
>> Miss Diaz
>> here.
>> Mr. Hersh
>> And President B
>> here.
>> We will now move to the approval or
minutes of the August 11th last
evening's meeting of committees of
council. Motion to
>> Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second for the
meeting minutes. Counselors, any
comments on the minutes?
>> Like to thank Mr. Harris for turning
them around.
>> I'm sorry, Madam President. These are
actually the minutes from the July 22nd
meeting.
>> Thank you very much. I changed that in
my notes because I was thinking we were
working on yesterday's meeting, but
that's not the case because that was
committees.
I'm going to withdraw my request for a
motion and start again. Uh we're moving
to the approval of the July 22nd regular
meeting of council minutes.
>> Motion to approve. Second.
>> Thank you. We do have a motion and a
second. Councilors, any comments on the
minutes from the July 22nd meeting?
>> Hearing none. Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. M.
>> I.
>> Mr. Royo.
>> Mr. Cle.
>> I.
>> Miss Craig.
>> Miss Diaz. I
>> Mr. Hirs
>> I
>> and President Baker
>> I thank you as always for keeping me
straight Mr. Harris.
>> Our next item on the agenda this evening
is proclamations, honors, awards and
resolutions of recognition. I don't
believe we have have any this evening.
Is that the case, Mr. Harris?
>> That is the case.
>> Thank you so much. That will then take
us to our first public comment period.
Again, this is reserved for residents
who have contacted the city clerk prior
to the cutoff before the meeting to
request the opportunity to address
council. Quick reminders. Just said
this, I'll say it again. Remind limit
comments are limited to three minutes
per speaker. Uh please uh be mindful of
equal time. Um and please begin with
your name and block of residents or your
municipality for the case of non- city
residents. Uh Mr. Harris has provided a
list of speakers um that is on the
screen before us this evening to help uh
continue to move things along. So this
is the order in which they were
submitted. speakers will uh come to the
microphone that's located over to your
left, my right. And so if you'd like to
pre-line up, that would help us uh make
sure that things keep moving. So our
first speaker this evening, Mr. Harris,
>> is Daryl Legacy.
>> Thank you. Mr. Legacy, are you here this
evening?
I did not happen to see him.
Our next speaker, Mr. Harris,
>> is Jontel Toland.
>> Mr. Toland.
And as you're coming to the microphone
right over here, uh, as the first
speaker, you may need to flip it on, uh,
the little, uh, onoff toggle to on.
Thank you.
Perfect.
>> It was on. Yeah, it was already on.
>> Thank you. Uh, John Tel Tolen, first and
only block of 68 Wise Aav. Uh,
I guess I'll start off by talking about
last meeting. Um, I'm appalled and
insulted by the way we were gas lit at
last council meeting. I held what I
wanted to say so that I could do some
digging so that I could think about why
you chose to regurgitate a script that
was given to you by the very people who
seek to cause us harm when you serve us.
Don't you think asking them questions at
the least and being transparent about
what you discuss with them, what
questions you actually ask would be
sound instead of trying to quell what
you think is a mob from the start of the
meeting when really it's just concerned
citizens of what you serve. Coming to
you with questions, information to share
and overall constructive dialogue. I
left angry because I was uh I left early
because I was angry. The more I look
into what AI data centers do to society
in general, not even just environmental
effects, it brings up anger, fear,
sorrow, anguish. I want our kids to have
a future. Don't you? Part of your job is
to work with us. There are people who
came to the last meeting with very
valuable information and I hope you took
it upon yourselves to look into any and
everything you could from last meeting
to now. Can you tell us about any
independent third party environmental
impact studies that were completed for
this project and where can the public
access it? Who in our community, not
corporate representatives, have been
consulted directly about this project
and where is that record? Will you
commit to showing up to a town hall
style question and answer where
residents, not just corporate PR teams,
can speak freely and have their
questions answered without time limits?
How will you ensure air noise and heat
pollution from this facility will not
harm our neighborhoods, especially black
and brown and low-income communities who
already face environmental burdens?
Given what happened in Memphis, where a
data center project disproportionately
impacted black communities and ignored
environmental justice concerns, how will
you guarantee that our city does not
repeat those same mistakes? Who will be
held personally accountable if the
project harms residents or the
environment? If you are truly committed
to making Langster safe and clean in
reference to the Dana Center, could you
put that comment in writing right now
for the public record? Have you took a
look at Memphis? Like I mentioned the
last time, have you looked at Tucson?
These are two just two cases with very
different results. Know that we will
continue fighting against this because
this this is our lives at stake, our
futures at stake. If you represent us
and yourselves, you should be alarmed
and angry. you should be jumping to make
moves to fight this given what's
happening in the country. When you plan
new developments, do you imagine who
will suffer the consequences? You do
think about the consequences, right? And
who suffers the most? It's not just the
rich who live in Chestnut Hill with tree
canopy streets. It's the families in the
southeast, the black and brown kids
playing near the train tracks, the
elders who already can't afford their
electric bills or their inhalers. Energy
prices will go up and a whole new cycle
of downward spiral and degradation of
this community's character will begin. I
wonder how many of you have already
considered any of this. If both these
data centers were to be built, it would
not only affect the city, it would
impact half a million people in the
surrounding county. This is not a win.
As the mayor or the governor said, it's
selling Lancaster sold to companies who
will use and abuse us and throw us away
when they are done. Why would you want
to why would you want or allow something
like this to go through unchecked unless
you alone benefit from it in some way?
Unless you are so naive that you would
believe everything these companies say
to you to be able to be swindled so
easily. Are you not insulted or enraged?
Thank you.
>> Thank you,
>> Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Brett Stanley.
>> Good evening.
>> Good evening. My name is Brett Stanley.
Living in Mountainville, working in
Lancaster at an aerospace lab.
I was born here and grew up watching the
farms and fields.
housing developments. I was too young
and distracted to care to do much about
that
seemed inevitable and out of my control.
I have a background in metal
fabrication.
I don't speak very often. So,
I was here at the first two meetings.
We kind of figured out this is like a
a fact finding process and uh yeah so uh
in custom fabrication workers ourselves
don't get to decide what companies we
service and I've had the privilege of
seeing direct influence on my community
in some ways but I'd be saddened and
unsurprised if some of the jobs created
for these centers are ped with already
work work locally. Um I'm opposed to AI
data centers and more qualified
individuals have discussed negative
implications at the previous two
meetings.
Um yeah, at the end of 2024, the company
I used to work for in Writesville uh
quadrupled their output or had been
asked to quadruple their output of data
center catalysts, which they've been
making for years, uh with the suggestion
that my employer would store the
catalyst longterm until needed. at the
end of 2024. I don't know when all this
money got moved around. Somebody
uh this leads me to believe that a
knowing investor had plans to manipulate
individuals to begin stockpiling with
potential knowledge that data centers
would be built. If I recall correctly,
these are selective catalytic reduction
units supposed to be good for three to
five years. Supposed to reduce 90% of
emissions turning the emissions into
nitrogen and water byproducts. But who's
going to be checking up on these
companies? How can we verify their, you
know,
facts? And what what is our recourse
when we find out it's bad just like
everywhere else has?
Um what do we do when uh they're
expanding to water and it threatens our
aquifers?
Uh as a community, we are trying to
piece together the true timeline of
events and how they were approved
without public knowledge. Uh time we
will have the full picture. Likely the
damage will have been done. Um we don't
know how this was approved logically or
ethically. However, working under these
assumptions, parts of these data centers
likely have already been fabricated
prior to our knowledge, not boosting the
economy. Potentially speculation, but
with all the wool that's been pulled
over our eyes between even the board and
what they've been told, uh what we've
been told, uh it's just alarming. That's
pretty much all I have to say.
Thank you, Mr.
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next is Alexander King.
>> Mr. King, good evening.
>> Good evening. I live on the 600 block of
North Ship Street and I've been reading
about the data center uh projects for
Lancaster City with increasing alarm in
the newspaper. My Memphis was mentioned
previously. My son lives in Memphis,
goes to college there, and he's been
telling me some real horror stories
about how uh data centers in the
African-American area of that city have
been really trashing that neighborhood.
Uh, one of the specific ways that
happens is through the backup diesel
generators, which is of course the most
dirtiest way you can make electricity.
But when the grid is over strained,
particularly in the summer because it's
also hot in Memphis, then they just need
to kick in those diesel generators to
have enough power for their computers.
Also, for a while now, actually, I've
been following the developments in
Abalene, Texas, which seems to become
increasingly uninhabitable from the
noise. So uh as is reported in the
newspaper you can have water cooled or
air cooled uh data centers and
apparently the ones in Langster are to
be air cooled which means they will be
very noisy. Inside a data center uh it
can be 95 dB or higher which is like
standing next to a jet airplane. Uh
outside the data center, you can have a
loud hum 24 hours 7. And some have
compared that to traffic on Highway 30,
for example. But traffic on Highway 30
is pretty minimal at 2 3 4 a.m. And the
jobs in these data centers uh are all
actually not all that great. Uh it's uh
routine maintenance. uh there's a a few
skilled people and the development
history with other dino centers going in
in other cities. Usually the most
skilled people are brought in. They're
not from the community whereas uh the
community members getting jobs there are
uh well minimal skill and not so great
pay in these places. And so I find it
really surprising that the city planner
was able to make this decision
unilaterally on what how to data center.
And so I implore council to evaluate
this thoroughly, look at reestablishing
noise ordinances for industrial uh uh
enterprises and thinking about how data
centers are something new and therefore
require a brand new classification in
the zoning and planning ordinances.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Mr. King.
>> Mr. Harris, our next speaker, please.
>> Next is Irene Grievous.
Miss Grievous.
>> Good evening. Irene Grievous, 900 block
of um West End Avenue. Um, I'm here this
uh evening following up from last
month's July uh 8 uh regarding my
property on 901 Manner Street and the
city's continued lack of response to my
repeated requests going back to 2021 for
third party inspections, arbitration,
and a clear path to resolution. For
years, I've been asking for a fair and
neutral way to resolve this. And for
years, nothing happened. Meanwhile,
Lancaster is in the middle of a major
housing crisis and this property could
be a home for a family right now if the
city will simply work with me instead of
leaving this matter in limbo. People in
the community have been asking me
directly to rent the home. Just last
week, someone had placed a note on the
back door. They work in the construction
field and were willing to make any
necessary repairs just to live there. A
man named Sean Potter who has done work
for me before and try contacting the
city for help um but got nowhere and
ignored. And just today um I was
approached by a gentleman by the name of
Charlie Brucey uh and with his
permission um he's in a desperate need
of housing. His and all the surrounding
units in the 200 block of West Chestn
Street are being covered or being
converted into $250 a night bed and
breakfast rentals. That change alone
would displace at least six families.
This is reality we're facing. Long-term
residents face uh are being priced out
and pushed out while available homes
just sit empty because the city refuses
to move forward to basic inspections and
mediation. Every week of delay means
another week a home uh standing empty.
Another week, families looking for a
place to live. In another week, a family
uh uh fails to take action that could
make a real difference in this in the
people's lives.
I am asking again for one, a prompt
independent inspection for 901 Manner
Street. Two, arbitration, a mediation to
to resolve any disputes, three a
timeline for resolution.
So, a home can be restored to a
residential use immediat immediately.
This is not just about my property. It's
about housing stability for Legac. You
have the power to help people in our
community, in our community house. I
urge you to act now before more families
are displaced. It's your job. This is
what you were elected to to do.
>> Thank you,
>> to help the residents. Thank you.
>> Thank you. councilors.
Uh, excuse me. I'll just take a just a
moment to remind you that we were copied
on um the followup from Miss Grievous
request last month on July 16th. So,
everyone has a copy of what that was.
Uh, Mr. Harris, our next speaker,
please.
>> Next speaker is uh Sarah
Inosa.
>> Good evening.
>> Hi, my name is Sarah Ederosa. I'm from
the 400 block of West Frederick and like
many people here, I'm here to address
the data center issue. I spoke at the
planning commission uh last week and
mentioned that I hold a master's degree
in international relations with an
emphasis in sustainable development. So,
I've studied extensively the importance
of resource management and the impact
this kind of digital infrastructure has
on communities specifically where
resources are already strained like in
Lancaster. The issue with the issues
with the data center are many and
community members have spoken to the
city council about these harms and will
you do tonight. Noise, air, and water
pollution, increases in utility costs,
being held politically hostage by a
massive corporation, the fact that
Cororeweave is a deeply unprofitable
company with many billions of dollars in
debt. And I'm sure that more people
tonight will enumerate these many harms.
I'll reiterate what I think is the most
concerning issue, which is the enormous
strain on our grid. On the low end, with
conservative estimates, this data center
would use quadruple the amount of energy
of all the houses in Lancaster City
combined. And I could talk about these
harms extensively, but I would like to
focus on the next steps that we're
looking for as a community. Last week, I
spoke to the planning commission among
many other concerned citizens, and the
planning commission acted immediately
with some concrete steps. And while
there's still a lot more we're looking
to see from the planning commission,
they scheduled a public hearing for
October 1st and engaged seriously with
the possibility of a new zoning
category, we're here to ask for the same
kind of concrete actions from our city
council because it has been almost a
month since this announcement was made
and for the planning commission. They
made steps within the meeting that we
came to them. Here are just a few
examples of the type of concrete actions
I'm referring to. Number one, you could
earmark the revenue from the building
permits for affordable housing, the $8
million that you've received. Someone
mentioned at the planning commission
meeting that it is easier to get an
energy guzzling million square foot data
center in Lancaster than it is to get
affordable housing. If this project is
inevitable, use the permit revenue for
the city's greatest need. Two, another
example, you could put pressure on Core
Weave to use renewable energy. There are
some data centers in the world that
attempt to center their mission
holistically around renewable energy.
Cororeweave is not one of these. Their
data centers in Europe use almost 100%
renewable energy, but in the states,
many of their data centers don't at all.
So why are we not putting this crash on
them? We know they're capable of it. I'm
running out of time, so I just want to
re-emphasize that I'm not here to uh
spit vitriol at you. I actually do
believe that many of you really really
care about this community and are
working on this. I'm here in a spirit of
collaboration to share what we believe
would be a specific and tangible next
step from you. We're really looking for
action. Thank you.
>> Thank you,
[Applause]
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is Patricia.
Good evening.
>> Hello. I'm from East Township.
I've been reading the articles in the
Langster newspaper concerning the
proposed data centers at Greenfield Road
and Harrisburg Pike. Preliminary
construction has already begun at the
Greenfield Road site. Prior to this to
purchasing the properties, it was
already approved. The backhanded zoning
approval is very disturbing and sends a
message to the community that obtaining
a bar was more important than any
inconveniences and hazards to residents.
I live less than a mile from the
Greenfield Road property along 34 Green
340 in Regent's Park condo development
and I have two main concerns with the
project. The health impact on the
residents and the excessive use of water
and electricity to run the operation.
The air and water quality compromised
due to the 70 plus diesel generators and
the waste water pumped back into the
waterways. Since I'm in close proximity
to the data center, I'm worried about
the noise from the generators and the
cooling equipment. According to a news
article in the August 9th, 2025 Langster
newspaper, a professor of environmental
health sciences at University of
Michigan School of Public Health, Rick
Nitel, stated, and I quote, "There's
evidence that noise disturbance can over
the long term lead to more serious
health problems like high blood
pressure, increased risk of stroke, and
hearing loss. The science certainly
shows that it can bad for us if we're
exposed at high enough levels for long
enough. End of quote.
In the same article, Jeff Stera of
Wilson Construction, who is doing the
work, says the noise will be like the
traffic noise on Route 30. I live right
near Route 30, and I can tell you the
noise at night can be very loud, and I
really don't want that to be doubled
with this new project.
Nitsel replies, and I quote, "The data
center may produce less and a highway
during the day. The center operates
around the clock, including at night
when highway traffic decreases." End of
quote. I asked the city of Lancaster to
put an ordinance in place to cover data
centers. While it may be too late,
though I hope not, for this center,
unless they want to expand in the
future, it will put a halt to the center
on Harrisburg Pike until the company
puts in place remedies for residents
concerns.
Nitel goes on to say that it is possible
to limit noise with air cooled equipment
designed to trap the noise from getting
out into the environment.
Secondly, the excessive water
electricity use is an environmental
issue. Will nearby residents experience
low water pressure? Who is paying for
the PPL substation to be erected on the
data center property?
Will residents see major increases in
their electric bills due to the
excessive use of electric? How will
waste water be treated and disposed of?
And there are many other answered
unanswered questions. City government
does have a response to provide a
healthy environment. Thank you.
>> Thank you so much,
>> Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is Nathan Bishop.
>> Good evening.
>> Good evening. My name is Nathan Bishop.
I'm a resident of the 100 block of
President A in Lancaster Township and
I'm a renewable energy transactions
attorney. I'm addressing you today
regarding the proposed Cororeweave data
centers out of concern for their impact
on the people and environment of
Lancaster. These data centers will bring
enormous monetary and environmental
costs. Right now, the data center
planned for 216 Greenfield Road will be
equipped with 72 diesel backup
generators. Our air quality is already
the 22nd in the nation for short-term
particle pollution. We need to make our
air cleaner, not more polluted. Along
with the new diesel generation, the
power consumption of the 100 megawatt
facility will be drawing from
Lancaster's existing power supplies,
which are composed of 33% coalbased
generation, leading to a huge increase
in greenhouse gas emissions.
The monetary costs of data centers are
already well documented. rateayers,
normal people end up paying higher
electricity prices when new data centers
draw upon existing transmission and
generation resources. I call the
council's attention to two reports on
this matter. The report titled
Extracting Profits from the Public: How
Utility Rate Payers Are Paying for Big
Tech's Power by Eliza Martin and Ari
Pesco of the Harvard Law School
Environmental and Energy Law Program and
the analysis of the 202526
RPM base residual auction prepared by
the independent market manager for PJM,
which is the regional transmission
organization servicing Lancaster.
This report demonstrates that normal
people are paying billions of dollars in
higher electricity bills as a direct
result of new data centers and that
these costs are only expected to get
worse. I call upon the city to reject
any further data sector applications and
with respect to the center plan for 216
Greenfield Road to coordinate with the
state public utility commission and PJM
to gain access to all agreements between
PJM and Cororeweave to insist on new
direct colllocated solar plus storage
generation paid for by Cororeweave to
service all of the electricity and
backup power needs of the facility which
would help bring green jobs to
Lancaster, prevent air and climate
pollution and prevent utility rate hikes
and to establish proactive restrictions
on the facility from switching to water
cooling systems and to address the
knowing concern issues. Thank you for
your time and attention to this matter.
>> Thank you,
>> Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next is Shauna Yordy.
>> Good evening.
>> Hi, I'm Shauna Yordy. I'm on the 800
block of Third Street. Uh I was here
last week for the planning commission
meeting and spoke uh about some similar
things and I heard a lot of people who
were numbers people and who are facts
people and I talked about how I'm a
feelings person.
That's what I have to give. And as a
feelings person, there's a lot of big
scary stuff that's going on in the world
right now. And I often find myself
wondering what I can do. And the only
thing that I come up with is that we
should all be whailing in the streets
right now. That's the thing that makes
the most sense to me. But nobody else is
doing that yet. So instead, I make art
and I hang out with kids and right now
I'm hanging out with some kids who are
four to eight years old and we're
building a world. We're building an art
installation where we're looking at
different perspectives. We've got a town
and a mountain and some water in the
underground. And when we're building
this world, we talk about our roles and
we talk about the impact of our actions
and how what we do in the town affects
the mountain and how what happens on the
mountain affects the salmon that we put
into our river. And there's different
kinds of people, right? There's number
people and there's feelings people and
there's kids and there's power people.
And right now it seems to me that you
guys are the power people and the power
people need to take some ideas from
these kids who come up with these
incredible ideas. They have all of these
out of the box solutions because they're
not bound by silly rules and ideas of
like well somebody said that there was
an ordinance that we have to do XYZ and
there's a law about the haha.
There's people in power who can change
that stuff and come up with innovative
ideas and new ideas just like the kids
can decide that they don't want a data
center in our town because what's going
to happen to the animals that live on
the mountain and how are we going to
breathe and how are we going to drink
the water and how are the ducks going to
stay upright on the pond that we built
when none of us can breathe. We're going
to have a public health crisis on our
hands. And I hear a lot of people
talking about um boosting the power grid
because it's going to take all of this
power and such and such and such. And
what I wonder is what actions can be
taken to boost the public health system
in Lancaster City to deal with the
effects that's going to happen when the
chronically ill people and the people
with asthma and the people with
migraines and the people who are on
inhalers can't breathe. And what's going
to happen when our kids can't breathe?
The kids can't eat the dollars. They
can't breathe the dollars. They can't
drink the dollars. They don't give a
about the dollars. They just want
to breathe. And so at that time maybe
like is that what happens is that we
don't do anything now and then the kids
can't breathe and then we're all wailing
in the streets because it's all that we
have left and all we can do is just be
feelings people crying in the streets.
What are you going to do so we don't get
to that place? What's going to happen?
How do we keep from getting there? Thank
you.
>> Thank you.
[Applause]
Mr. Harris, our next speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is Gerald Gerald Grinder.
>> Is Gerald Grryer here.
>> Our next speaker, Mr. Harris,
>> is Dan Wel.
Good evening.
>> Good evening.
>> Uh Dan Wiggle, uh Clarendon Drive. Um as
you may have noticed, there's a petition
going around
u there's a petition going around um in
our community about the data center. Uh
we have hundreds of signatures on it.
It's been in the news. Obviously, this
is a big deal to our community. I'd like
to take my time tonight first to read
the petition to you all. As AI companies
descend on Pennsylvania to build data
centers, local governments need to make
a choice. Stand up to big tech or sell
out their constituents. In Lancaster
City, we're facing the construction of
two AI data centers that have gone under
the radar until recently. Setting aside
the negative effects of the global AI
race, these data centers will cause
price hikes for utilities, lower the
supply of water and electricity, and
create harmful new air and noise
pollution. Across the country, many
communities that have become sites for
data centers have been forced to deal
with rolling blackouts and low water
pressure while watching their utility
bills become more and more expensive. We
don't want that to happen in Lancaster
City. We call on Lancaster City
government to do the following. One,
city council must request from the
planning commission an ordinance that
covers the zoning of data centers and
resend the zoning officer's decision to
zone the Harrisburg Pike and Greenfield
Road data centers as wholesale trade and
storage.
They are not warehouses.
Two, Mayor Sarra and city council must
work with the public to pass a plan that
insulates Lancaster residents from the
negative effects of data centers. for
example, price hikes for utilities, low
water pressure, and rolling blackouts.
Three, city government must act with
complete transparency
and not issue any further permits to
data centers until these changes have
been made. Finally, we call on Lancaster
City to be a leader in Pennsylvania and
stand up for working people like you all
over the interests of big tech
companies. Now, I'd like to pull the
room. Of those in the room tonight, many
of you, I believe, have signed the
petition. For those who have not, who
have heard of it for the first time, I'd
like a show of hands. How many of you
are with us in our demands and stand
with us?
For the record, nearly everyone. Please
keep your hands raised for a moment. Um,
to you sitting up front, I turn the
question on you. Do you hear us? And are
you with us? Please raise your hands.
a bit higher, please
>> everyone on city council. Mayor Sarra,
do you hear us and are you with us?
>> This is a conversation that I want to
continue to have because there are some
of the things that you're demanding that
I can't I can't respond to most
especially around public utility
commission and the regulation of
electricity. And so I I hear you on the
air quality, water, uh use utilization,
which this facility will use less water
than its previous use, um which is LSC
Communications, which is one of our top
10 water customers. Um noise
independently evaluated. So what I can
say is that I am hearing you, council is
hearing you. are having conversations
about all of the things that you're
asking for. But there are some things
that are outside and beyond the capacity
of this body to respond to, most
especially energy regulation, PJM, PUC,
and how PPL is responding to questions
about rate hikes, rolling blackouts,
etc. We cannot answer those questions.
>> Thank you, Mr. Griner. I also uh I echo
that sentiment. I do have some uh
responses after the end of public
comment to that effect, but I do
appreciate your comments and I do hear
you and I know that many members of
council have shared your concerns. We've
spoken to me, spoken to the
administration and members of the city
government.
>> Thank you. I look forward to your
actions.
[Applause]
Coun Council Craig.
>> Thank you, Council President. Um, I am
very interested in everything that
everyone has to say,
but it's really difficult when someone's
at the speaker and and I know you want
to applaud them because what they're
saying is good, but if we can't hear
them,
you know, then I'm getting half of what
they're saying. So, can we click instead
of clap
>> there? Thank you, Council Craig. Um, Mr.
Harris, our next speaker.
>> Our next speaker is uh Joe Ellen
Wiznowski.
>> Good evening,
everyone.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you all for being here, especially
our council and mayor and for all your
service to our community. We appreciate
everything you do and for being here. I
also appreciate my fellow community
members. PS, I'm in the 200 block of
North Pine Street and I own a business
here in Lancaster City, 100 block of
Chestnut. So, I uh respect what everyone
is having to say here and appreciate all
the amazing data. What I have a specific
question on is that the city of
Lancaster voted last November to be part
of home rule which was mo most uh was
pushed forward and and discussed and
paid for to discuss how that was going
to be implemented with the city did vote
yes to it. I'm writing what I haven't
seen anything updated on the city of
Lancaster website as to how we as
citizens can implement our right to
petition ordinances. I'm not even sure
if this was an ordinance passed, but I'm
looking at article 7, ordinances, which
says general proposals increases
requirements for public notice prior to
adoption, and article 11 adds citizen
ability to petition to propose,
reconsider, or appeal an ordinance by
referendum. I'd like to know how our
council members and our governance here
are actually if this is an ordinance
that was passed, why the public wasn't
allowed the petitioning uh that was
guaranteed by us passing home rule,
which again I haven't seen any updates
since all the things have been put on
the website as to how our go how our
people can use our government that we
pass to actually be a participant in
these situations which do affect every
single person who lives and works in
this city. And I leave all these
wonderful people who have done amazing
research to give all the details, but
that's something I specifically want
addressed to our community. And you
know, we had letters coming out saying,
"Yes, please vote for home rule. Here's
what it's going to do for us. Now, how
can we as people who have mil hundreds
here have been coming to these events
and represent only a part portion, but
how do we get the word out to the rest
of our community how they can be
involved as well in the governing of our
city? Thank you.
>> Thank you, Miss Mosowski.
To um to address that very specific
question, I do think it's important to
mention that this was not an ordinance
that was brought forward to council uh
because of the processes that the owner
of the property chose to take. It did
not come before any uh body of the city
administration, board, commission, or
authority.
Thank you.
appreciate that, Mr. Harris. The next
speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is Jennifer Seagull.
>> Good evening.
>> Hi, my name is Jennifer Seagull. Um, but
everyone here knows me as Coral Wrights.
I live in Marietta, but I host events
here in Lancaster City and rely on
people's willingness to travel to
Lancaster to pay my bills. And most of
my favorite people live here, but more
than that,
we all breathe the air. and whether or
not I can is dictated by you all doing
your job as city council members. This
data center is bigger than just
Lancaster City. At the last at the last
meeting, there was some opess around
what Carissa Technology Techna
Technology Parks overall plans were for
the other property. It's as clear as day
on Carissa's website that their
intentions are for the lots that they've
purchased four data centers across two
sites. They are already advertising it
to their clients. But what you did make
clear last council meeting was that no
permits for the other site had been
filed. We need to move while we still
have options. At the planning meeting
last week, it was determined that not
only can you create an appropriate
ordinance for future data centers, but
also for the one that you implied
couldn't that you couldn't interrupt the
process of because you haven't made any
moves since last council meeting. I'm
assuming you're either getting something
for rolling over and playing dead or
you've got the most severe case of
people pleasing I have ever seen. Except
who are you pleasing? because none of us
are pleased.
People pleasing only ever hurts people
and enables bad behavior. In this case,
in corporations, AI isn't going away.
Data centers aren't going to get kinder
and better managed. We are at the very
beginning of a technological revolution.
And right here, right now, you all get
to decide if it's going to be in favor
of the people or the corporations. And I
believe that each and every one of you
has the integrity inside of you to
choose the people. And if you decide to
roll over and play dead, then you better
know that protests will be regular
occurrences that you all will have to
contend with. Please be brave. Start the
ordinance work now. We can be a positive
example for the country. But if you
refuse, then know that everyone in this
county will know that every single one
of you, including the mayor, is a coward
and that you are to blame for the
technocratic takeover of Lancaster,
Pennsylvania. Everyone will know that
you are the reason they can't afford
their electricity. That you are the
reason they can't hear themselves think.
You are the reason their home
depreciated significantly. You are the
reason that visitors stop visiting and
spending money in our city. You are the
reason that people can't breathe. I
suspect some of you never thought that
you would be managing more than standard
things. But this is the reality. This is
what you signed up for. This is bigger
than Lancaster City. It's bigger than
Lancaster County. If you can't handle
that pressure, then you shouldn't be in
government. If you can't handle showing
up for people in this, then there is no
way we can count on you to push back
when ICE arrives. They're already in the
area. Everything is connected and
impacts everything else. We all breathe
the same air for the sake of all of us.
Rise up and actually lead. Thank you.
>> Thank you,
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is Samuel Pollock.
>> Good evening.
>> Hello. It's uh you guys hear me? Samuel
Pollock from 100 block of Uclid Avenue
behind Regal Cinemas.
Uh, thanks everybody for coming out. I'm
here to speak about two things. It's
going to be the data center and I think
the civilian police review board I saw
was later on the agenda. I'll try to
keep it quick. People pretty much I
think have got and why these data
centers are so horrifying and terrible.
Uh, lived in Langster for a long time.
One of my favorite things to do here is
hiking around the county. You know,
Langster Conservancy. We got all those
cool some very close Langster City.
Actually, Windolf Landing. The wing stem
is starting to go off right now. Uh I
think the problem is like we keep having
it's like I'm like a feelings person
too. I'm also worried about climate
change because reality is it's simply
not a hoax. It's true. In fact use is
happening to the pollinators. It's
happening there. Climate change is very
very real. And I worry that like when we
bring up like concerns like oh don't
worry like we're going to get the grid
for when all this new electricity comes
so it'll be able to handle it. But it's
like wasn't that part of the problem
though? Because fossil fuels do the
electricity and that's what's destroying
us here locally too. So it's like that
doesn't really make me feel better if
the factual basis is still there. That
makes any sense. And the other thing is
I we talked about like renewables for
these things. Know I saw I've also read
you know some of these companies talking
about oh we want these net supposedly
like uh net zero AI data centers but
even these ones in Europe they're using
some fossil fuels at the end of the day.
Even the best ones in Finland use like
5%. And that's only like best case
scenario. The reality is if you look
this up nobody really knows how much
these are going to use in the future. In
fact, all we know is that they're
exponentially increasing. And the only
thing that can keep that round the clock
is fossil fuels to to do that for when
it's the big thing. In fact, that's the
whole thing. Facts don't care about your
feelings. Fossil fuels will be the only
thing that will be able to power these
increasing amounts. Literally, you can't
do this without fossil fuels. I.e. this
contributes to climate change. I.e. this
is destroying our planet. That is
although that's global, it's also local.
It's happening right here at the
conservies that we all enjoy. It's
happening everywhere. and the Civilian
Police Review Board. It's it may seem
different, but in some ways it's the
same. Like you're telling us to feel
better, like we're gonna do a civilian
police review board. And I thought the
whole thing would be an advisory joke,
frankly, when I looked at it, but at
least I thought it'd be something. But
then I was so disappointed to see that
half of it's police officers. They're
like current police officers that like
the Lakes CB chief is on that review
board. And then you you not just past
law enforcement officers, you're the
mayor is going to be appointing current
law enforcement officers. And that's not
the case in other civilian like that's
not the case with uh New York as I
that's not case with what did like
Martinsburg West Virginia you know
they're they are actually civilians are
appointed there are you can't even be a
past law enforcement officer for some of
those review boards in New York City you
can't even have been in law enforcement
or public any of those types of things
period here we're talking about the
police investigating themselves how the
heck does that work literally the police
are the civilian review board that's not
a civilian review board that's a police
review board I'm sorry that's that's all
I got to today.
[Applause]
>> Mr. Harris, our next speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is Christine Kennedy.
>> Good evening. You can feel free to bring
that down a little lower.
Should
>> or not? I hope that's not as low as it
goes. There we go. Okay, perfect. Thank
you.
My name is Christine Kennedy. I live in
the first block of Market Street in
Lancaster, Pennsylvania.
And I come today to
tell a little bit about what I've
learned and where I was wrong with some
of the comments I made at the prior
city council meeting.
Um,
some of those were I've learned that
data centers are not necessarily
Bitcoin, which was the Bitcoin mining
experience that I had uh been near and
deafened by. That indoor data centers
are very different than outdoor Bitcoin
mining center that I experienced. And
that fans and water are not the only
alternatives for cooling at a data
center. And that committed to starting
in 2025 that all their new data centers
will incorporate liquid cooling
capabilities.
I questioned what liquid cooling
capabilities would include and according
to Wikipedia,
liquid cooling fluids can use water and
liquid dialectic fluids of which
Wikipedia has a huge list of what that
could include.
I was glad to see that the city of
Lancaster is looking to engage a
consultant with knowledge and experience
with immediate long-term considerations
and mitigation options of data center
construction operation and for example
what potential hazards may be associated
with any spills of liquid dialectics.
I believe that corporations purchasing
land and developing data centers are
moving more rapidly than local
municipalities are prepared for. Similar
in many ways to the explosion of the
internet. My hope is that we can educate
our elected officials, municipal
employees and residents with good
information and quickly learn as best we
can from the experience of other
municipalities.
Among my questions now is how might we
be an example to other communities that
as we're playing catchup with this train
that's running so fast, how might we be
able to do what we can when we can to do
for example
what Sarah Henosa
recommended and Nathan Bishop and Dan
Wigle. I'm very impressed with the kind
of research and the resources that we
have right here in Lancaster. And I was
proud of our city becoming an example to
small cities across the country of
having a comprehensive plan that
incorporates references to all ages, not
just certain ages and all people. We can
be an example, too, of fighting the
fight to catch up and do the best we can
and maybe and make us a community that
Cororeweave might want to point to
because they've done the best they
really can to help us. Thank you.
>> Thank you,
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next is I'm sorry, Lindsay Fitting.
>> Good evening.
>> Hello. My name is Lindsay Fitting. I
live on the 500 block of West James
Street and I'm here to talk about, you
guessed it, the AI data centers. So, as
a resident of Lancaster City, I fear for
our access to water and electricity if
this data center is built. We already
have so much evidence of AI data centers
causing droughts, such as in Texas,
where all their data centers combined
are projected to use 50 billion gallons
of water this year. Residents who are
trying to just drink water, shower, and
water their plants are being told to
conserve their water for the sake of
these data centers. Doesn't this sound
reminiscent of every other environmental
disaster caused by huge corporations?
Somehow the solution is always that we
need to take shorter showers. Air
cooling has been touted as a solution to
water shortages. However, this is not an
option because coreweave proudly states
on their website that liquid cooling is
essential for large-scale AI
performance. There are other ways
regular citizens will have to pay to
accommodate AI.
My friend in Illinois now pays $200 a
month for electricity and his
one-bedroom apartment. His boss pays 600
per month for his house because their
electric company, Commed EMED, passes
the cost of electricity to all of its
customers to keep up with demand created
by AI data centers. For comparison, my
electric bill in Lancaster for a
one-bedroom has been $30 to $40 per
month since 2022, and so was his in
Chicago. The CEO of Core Weeave claims
the Lancaster data center will drive
economic growth, but for who? himself
and his shareholders. Not the single
parent trying to make sure their
children have water to drink and bathe.
Not the 20some year old server working
doubles to barely afford their one red
apartment. And not the first time home
buyer getting ready to pay more bills
than they ever have in their life. I
don't care that you made a silly picture
of your dog seemingly out of nowhere. I
don't care that you think chat GBT is a
substitute for a therapist. And I don't
care that AI wrote your essay so you can
graduate and not have to think about
these things that you were supposed to
be learning. I speak for all Lancaster
County residents when I say we will be
paying for these AI data centers with
our quality of life and wallets if we do
not stop it. Thank you.
>> Thank you,
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker, please.
>> Next speaker is R is Reagan Layman.
Good evening.
>> Good evening. Um, my name is Reagan
Layman and I live on the 500 block of
North Shippen Street and I appreciate
the council giving us an opportunity
today to speak on the issues that are
pressing our city. Um, since the last
city council meeting, I know that the
city has published an FAQ on AI data
centers on their website. And while my
three minutes doesn't allow me to
address each point, I'd like to address
some of the statements on the web page.
In response to the stated impacts on air
quality, I understand that the PA
Department of Environmental Protection
is reviewing the permit on backup diesel
generators for these AI data centers.
However, this doesn't address the larger
picture that the fact that we're seeing
across the nation, we're restarting coal
plants in order to fuel these AI gener
um AI data centers. Not to mention,
we're now seeing three Mile Island is
being restarted to power a Microsoft AI
data center as well. So, in the end,
we're impacting the air quality of not
just Lancaster, but of all Pennians.
Additionally, are we supposed to simply
trust that these diesel generators will
only be run as backup power? Are we
going to have to depend on
self-reporting from these AI data
centers? How are we going to enforce
that these permits are being followed
and won't change in the future?
Secondly, when it comes to noise
pollution, we're developing on the
developer to self assess the noise
impact. Of course, if they're
self-reporting, I would assume that
they're motivated to report it as
neutral. They want to finish this
project. They want to make money. You
also state that the city will be
reviewing the study, but given that this
administration seems to be already
biased towards these data centers, this
whole FAQ page seems very pro data
center, I have a difficult time trusting
that assessment. Once again, I ask, what
are the means of enforcement if these AI
data centers end up contributing to
noise pollution? These companies don't
care about us. They only care about
profit.
Most fines are a slap on the wrist to a
billion dollar company. Will we be tied
up in endless litigation if we pursue
legal recourse? While I understand that
the mayor is pursuing a community
benefits agreement with the data
centers, my understanding is that
municipal zoning ordinances are easier
to enforce than CBAs. So why wouldn't we
start setting these protections, these
zoning protections in place now during a
time when our clean air and water
protections are being stripped away at
the federal level? We can't afford any
complacency on the state and municipal
level if we're going to protect our
neighbors.
Despite the public turnout I've seen at
two different meetings so far, despite
the thousands of emails that I know that
you have received, um when I checked the
agenda earlier today, I didn't see
anything about the data centers. And I'm
really disappointed. I'm asking that the
council today to amend the agenda to
take action and start this resoning
process. Data centers are not
warehouses. They should have never been
categorized as warehouses and skipped a
planning commission meeting. Let's take
steps now to protect our communities
before it's too late. Thank you. I yield
my time. Thank you.
Mr. Harris, our next speaker.
>> Next speaker is Frank Aralo.
>> Good evening.
>> Frank Archolio, Old Trinity Place. So,
at the last council meeting, I asked the
great Watergate question, which is what
did you know and when did you know it?
Well, I think I've got some answers. The
planning commission had no idea. They
had to read it in the newspaper. The
city council, according to council
president, said, and I quote, "We were
made aware of this not terribly long
ago. It's new information for many of
us." So then, who knew? Well, I think
there's only one body after that. I
think it's the administration. The we
first found out about it in February
with a nice LNP article announcing the
project and quoting the mayor as saying
she was excited to support the trans
transformation. It was a great win-win
for Lancaster. No mention of zoning
process. No mention of anything having
to do with what needs to be done in
order to make it a reality.
In July, we finally get another L&P
article. Public input may be limited.
How about non-existent? What? How is
this possible? Well, the mystery was
cleared up at the zoning board meeting
by Betsy Logan, the bureau chief of
planning.
The truth is that the developer got
letters from the city approving the
zoning
before the property was even purchased.
Long before February 19th, touting how
wonderful it is, they had already
approved the thing. Isn't that great?
The city must have been either in
negotiations or reviewing whatever was
sent to them for months. But guess what?
They kept it quiet. And the approval was
based on bogus zoning as wholesale trade
and storage. In other words, a warehouse
in order to avoid any scrutiny. And now
we stand here being told it's too late
to do anything. How
how deceitful, how underhanded that is.
Authoritarian behavior. And we, believe
me, we know what authoritarian behavior
is because we see it every day in DC.
I called it and I have called it zoning
fraud. And I think that that zoning
determination needs to be rescended and
be rescended now. Thank you.
Mr. Harris, our next speaker, please.
>> Our last speaker is Tony Dastra.
>> Good evening.
>> It's an evening. Uh Tony Dastra, 700
block of New Holland Avenue. So, what I
signed up to talk about was actually
parking. Um but I'm going to connect
these two issues because you have some
issues that web out over time. The city
parking issue. It depends on how you
look at it and what perspective that
issue is. Maybe the city's implementing
positive changes for safety and it's
taking away your perceived parking so
you now feel left out. Maybe the city
isn't doing enough about the parking
situation. Maybe you feel like your
parking isn't protected. You need a
residential zone. There are wicked
problems in our community that have gone
poorly addressed for decades. This
really isn't solely on you guys. This is
before you, administrations before you.
But right now, we're looking at a
problem with the data center. I won't
belabor details because I've I've said a
lot about it. I had feelings at the
planning commission meeting, but we're
looking at one big issue that the public
is looking for y'all to act on, to say
something on. And I understand that you
may need to ask questions of
professional advice on what you can and
can't do, but it
You're kind of speaking volumes by not
saying much at all.
I agree with a lot of the sentiments in
this room. Um,
I'm very disappointed in this.
I appreciate to the prior comments
because unfortunately
we want to demonstrate that we can have
a good local government. Why? Because
the top needs to mirror the bottom. And
right now, unfortunately, the behaviors
of not just this body, but bodies across
this country are mirroring the top. It's
just the marketing is better.
We have a comprehensive plan. here. We
finally put the RFP out for, but y'all
really need to ask the planning
commission to act on this and y'all need
to do something yourselves as well. You
need to speak out. You need to People
need to see that you're aligned in the
regulation of this development because
the damage it could do will affect us
for generations to come much like the
issue has.
>> Thank you.
>> There were two that were not present
when their names are were called. I'm
going to call them in the order which
they were on the list. Uh Daryl Legassi.
>> That's me.
>> Yes. Good evening.
>> Thank you. Sorry. Um I came here
directly from a meeting with my family
about end of life care for my father. So
I hope that that uh shows how important
this is to me.
>> I'm very sorry to hear that. And I may
also have you start with your
>> I'm sorry. Uh so I'm in the 100 block of
North.
>> Thank you.
>> Um so I have a couple points, a couple
questions and a charge to the council.
So, first I want to say that um for
those of us that were here, I think it
was maybe two city council meetings ago
when we heard the um budget and all of
the information about where our money is
being spent. You may have remembered
that the storm uh the wastewater
treatment plant had to purchase a quote
unquote sliver of land from PPL and that
required a land development plan. So, we
who own the wastewater treatment plant
were doing a land development plan to
ourselves, the city. And yet, the AI
data center, nah, they don't need one.
We don't have to worry about them doing
one. We'll just trust them. That is
ludicrous. That is preposterous.
Two, I am very concerned with the fact
that the governor and the mayor are both
so gung-ho about this. And and frankly,
the mayor, I understand that you have
said there's there's little we can do.
There are restrictions in place. There
are things that we can't um undo. What
you could do is speak out. You could say
we are not welcome here. We can't stop
you, but you're not welcome here. You
could say Lancaster is closed for
business for AI data centers in the
future. It's not that hard. So your sort
of cavalier and frankly dismissive
attitude tonight makes me think that you
are fully fullthroated in behav in in
favor of these. So here are some
questions. Who is going to be
responsible for checking to make sure
that these data centers do not go one
inch outside of the current footprint
which would then of course trigger all
sorts of oversight? Two, who's going to
be responsible for making sure that
these diesel generators are only
operated as testing during the day as
the um requirement says? Three, who's
going to make sure that those generators
do not operate for more than 100 hours
per month as the agreement says? Four,
who's going to make sure that they never
switch to water cooling down the line
after we have let them come in and we
say, "Oh, well, they're already here. We
don't really have anything we can do
about it." So, here's my charge to
everybody on city council. And actually,
Councelor Royal specifically, this is
your chance to distance yourself from
some of the mayor's policies. You are
running for mayor this fall. You are
probably going to win and this is your
chance to say no. This is different. The
mayor has decided she's for this. She
doesn't care. This is your chance to be
different. The rest of the council,
we've been told over and over that
there's nothing we can do. The
regulation is what it is. There's two
things about that. One, I would really
like to know what communication happened
between the mayor and the zoning officer
when this decision was made.
I don't believe that he just saw this
and said, "Oh, sounds like a warehouse
to me." And just pass this. That seems
ridiculous.
So, all of these things that we can't
undo. We're not allowed to change things
retroactively. We have a city councelor
or a solicitor. Let's start gumming up
the works. If they can use um loopholes
to call a data center a warehouse, we
can use loopholes to make it hard for
them to get equipment in. We can make
use loopholes to make it hard for them
to get construction equipment in. There
are all sorts of things that we could
do. And the fact that we're not even
trying these things speaks volumes.
>> Thank you, Mr. Line.
There was
there was one additional speaker who
wasn't present when their name was
called and that was Gerald. So I'd like
to give them the opportunity uh if they
are present to speak.
If not I believe that's our final
commenter for this period. Mr. Harris,
is that correct?
Thank you very much. I want to thank all
of our speakers and everyone who's here
tonight. I want to reiterate again that
I and many members of council do share
uh some of the same concerns as you
shared this evening. I want to assure
you that the city is working on
independent reviews of noise studies and
all manner of environmental impacts um
that are within our power to control.
I'm advocating for updates and
modernization of our noise ordinance
that addresses the findings. Um these
things are really really important to
get right and in my experience in
government uh that more time than I wish
and we all wish that they would. Uh, but
we're also working to get answers from
our utility providers and state level
entities for things like electricity
usage, uh, rates, um, and more that are
out of city government control. I want
to be really clear that we don't set
electricity rates. We don't have a seat
at the table, unfortunately, when it
comes to that. Uh, but we've been
working to get answers. Um, I'm
committed to keeping the public uh uh
informed about updates as more become
available um through that FAQ page and
also through uh our regular council
meetings. So, I do thank you all for
being here. That concludes our first
public comment period for this evening.
Um we do have our uh additional agenda.
If anyone wishes to excuse themselves
for the rest of the agenda, that's okay.
And now would be the time to do that. We
will move on to the next item on our
agenda which is reports requested by
council confirming Mr. Harris that we
don't have any of those this evening. Is
that correct?
>> Thank you. The next item on our agenda
is reports of committees of council
meetings. Those were held yesterday on
August 11th, 2025.
I'll give us just a moment to let folks
appear.
Our first is public safety committee
councelor Diaz.
>> Thank you councelor Diaz. Uh public
works committee council hir.
>> Thank you council president. The public
works committee did meet. We had one
agenda item resolution 54 which is
authorizing an agreement with the
Lancaster County Conservation District
which appears later on our agenda this
evening. That concludes the public works
uh report of the public works committee.
Thank you. Economic Development
Committee Councelor Med.
>> Uh, thank you, Council President. The
Economic Development Committee did not
meet.
>> Thank you. Finance Committee, Councelor
Royo.
>> Thank you, Council President. Uh, the
finance committee meeting did or I'm
sorry, the finance committee did meet.
Uh, we had one item on the on the
agenda. Uh, we heard from Director of
Administrative Services Tina Campbell
yesterday for the 2025 midyear budget
report. Overall, the city's finances are
on pace as budgeted. uh budgeted revenue
is slightly ahead and budgeted expenses
are below where they are expected to be
at this point. Uh this is mostly due to
current staff vacancies which are
temporary and are looking to be filled
this year. That concludes my uh report
and uh for the committee.
>> Thank you very much. Community planning
committee council Craig.
>> Thank you council president. Community
planning did meet. We had one item on
the agenda. That's administration
resolution number 55 2025 granting a
projection easement for Lancaster
parking authority.
>> Thank you very much. And personnel
committee councelor cl.
>> Thank you president. The personnel
committee met last evening August 11 and
reviewed the appointments to the
downtown investment district authority
and a board of plumbing examiners. And
the committee also reviewed
reappointments to the sign commission,
public art advisory board, higher
education authority, and the board of
plumbing examiners. That concludes my
report.
>> Thank you very much, councelor Clest.
That takes us into our legislative
agenda this evening. We will begin with
those nominations for appointment. So,
I'll turn it back over to council.
>> Thank you, council president. Madame
President, I make a motion to appoint
Katie Sheifflet to the downtown
Investment District Authority for a term
from August 12,
2025 to December 31st of 2029.
Mason Soda to the board of plumbing
examiners for a term from September 12,
2025 to September 12, 2026. And we
appoint Molly Kirkov to the sign
commission for a term from August the
31st of 2025 to August the 31st 2028.
C Sava Hung Benton, Barry Khoser, and
Rachel Fening Hills to the public art
advisory board for the terms from July
31st, 2025 to July 31st, 2027.
Gene Wglers to the Higher Education
Authority for a term from January 1st,
to January 1st, 2030.
and Eric Weiss, Barry Soder, Shaun Way,
and Trent Meyers to the board of
plumbing examiners for terms from
September 12, 2025 to September 12,
2026.
>> Motion to approve second.
>> We have a motion, excuse me, and a
second for our nominations for
appointment and reappoint this evening.
Uh counselors, any comments on the
appointments or reappoints?
from the public
>> hearing. None. Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. Med.
>> I.
>> Mr. Royal.
>> Mr. Please.
>> I.
>> Miss. Greg.
>> Miss. Diaz.
>> I.
>> Mr. Hersh.
>> President B.
>> I.
>> And we thank those members of our of our
community for their volunteer service.
Next item on the agenda, item B is
historic district. Mr. Harris, if you if
we've ready.
>> Yes, Madam President. Consider
nomination. I'm sorry. Consider the
following application recommendation
from historical architectural review
board for improvement to property within
the historic district. Uh Jeff Baldman,
owner of 134 North Street, requests
installation of an exterior spiral
staircase on a second story rear porch.
And that application was recommended for
approval by the historical architectural
review board.
Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second for um the
historic district items. Councelor
Craig, do you have any notes on these to
add?
>> I don't.
>> Councilors, we received notes on the
application and recommended. And this
was recommended for approval um by the
historical architecture review board.
I'll ask if there's any applicants or
members of the review board um that are
present that have anything additional to
add.
hearing. None. Any any additional
council comments on the approvals
from the public on the project
>> hearing? None. Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. M.
>> I.
>> Mr. Royal.
>> Mr. Please.
>> I.
>> Miss. Craig.
>> Miss. Diaz.
>> I.
>> Mr. Hersh.
>> President B.
>> I.
>> As we mentioned earlier, item C on our
agenda was not taken up by the public
safety committee last evening. So we
move to item D on our agenda which is
resolutions. We have resolution number
50 2025. Mr. Harris,
>> a resolution of the city council of the
city of Lancaster authorizing the proper
officials of the city of Lancaster to
enter into an agreement
uh to enter into a ground lease with
partners for environmental stewardship
and to take any and all actions to
consummate the transactions contemplated
by the agreement.
Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> Again,
>> we have a motion and a second. Council
Craig, this is coming up for community
planning.
>> Thank you, Council President. Um, we
reviewed this in committee um a few
weeks ago and it was um brought forth to
today. uh administration res resolution
502025 authorizing a grant authorizing a
ground lease agreement for a Sunnyside
environmental center.
Um we were presented by um our our
solicitor Mr.
provided information on a two-part
action,
an agreement to enter into a ground
lease and a ground lease and a ground
lease.
This will be a
lengthy process for partners for
environmental stewardship to design and
environmental center on nine
on the peninsula and then seek permits
to
construct the center. The ground lease
provides them with a 99-year lease on
the property to
construct and develop the center. The
city will continue to own
the nearly 9 acre tract where the
environmental center will be located.
The agreement to enter into the lease
will will govern the structure of the
city's respon response
relationship with partners for env
environmental stewardship until the
project definitely moves forward. Then
the lease agreement will be signed. All
all costs for the project will be borne
by partners with for environmental
stewardship. The city will have
responsibilities related to the preserve
surrounding the center. And those are
the notes that I've taken that involve
the sunny side peninsula.
>> Thank you very much, Councelor Craig. I
know we have uh director delves coming
uh to to address us this evening. I want
to thank you for being here. Um in
addition to your notes, I would also add
I think I recall that um there was a lot
of work done about community benefit for
this environmental center um and
insurance that it would uh benefit the
community directly adjacent to the
Sunnyside Peninsula. Director Delos, if
you're in your comments tonight, if you
could also ensure to address that as
well.
Lights on. That looks good. You might
have to get a little closer to it, but
otherwise Okay.
>> Good evening, council. Is that okay?
>> Yes, that's perfect. Thank you.
>> Uh uh very good. And uh thank you
councelor Craig and uh President B uh
for the questions. Uh I'm so pleased to
be here to talk about this uh action and
this project here tonight. As you know,
uh this has been a long time in the
making. And uh if you'll bear with me, I
just want to go over some uh context
related to the project. I know it will
be a recap uh for many of you here
tonight, but I did want to just take a
few moments to uh talk about how we got
here. Uh and also if there's anybody uh
new in the audience listening, I think
it's good to have the background as
well. Um
I I will try to keep it brief though and
I know uh we have a long night here. Uh,
as many of you know, in October of 2023,
the city adopted um completed and
adopted uh its first comprehensive plan
in 30 years. One of the big ideas in the
comp plan entitled our future Lancaster
was to enhance community access to the
Konosoga River.
In order to help launch this vision, the
comp plan called for a nature and
recreation preserve at the north end of
the Sunnyside Peninsula and have that uh
that preserve anchored by an
environmental center. Uh, city staff
issued a request for proposals in
November of 2023
um and then later issued a conditional
award uh to the Partners for
Environmental Stewardship in January of
2024.
Um, so uh it's been a little while since
uh 2024 uh January 2024. Since that
time, uh, the solicitor's office and our
outside council have negotiated a series
of agreements with PEES, and the
resolution before you tonight, uh, is
really the culmination of that series of
work. And, uh, the purpose is to
authorize the long-term, uh, ground
lease for the environmental center
building and grounds, as councelor Craig
pointed out. Um, also wanted to, uh,
reiterate that, uh, our city solicitor,
Mr. Hanburgger. Uh he did speak to city
council uh during the July committee
meeting about about the ground lease
specifically. We do have our outside
counsel uh here tonight, Mr. Igor Plus.
uh in case you have any additional
questions uh specifically about the
legal agreement.
Uh although the focus here tonight
really is on uh on the ground lease
agreement uh it is worth noting that uh
PS partners for environmental
stewardship is making progress on the
broader initiative as well. the
executive director of PS, Miss Diana
Martin, is present here this evening.
And uh wanted to give her a chance just
to say a few words about the ongoing
work. And I think um President B that
that speaks to your opening question
about how all of these pieces fit
together for uh the community
engagement, ultimately the community uh
benefit for uh the immediate southeast
neighborhoods and for really the city
and the region as a whole. Um
I I would say ultimately uh at the end
of the day what what we're trying to
achieve here PS is responsible for
designing and constructing a worldclass
green building uh on Sunnyside and
establishing uh environmental education
programs uh and other uh similar
programming to serve city residents. Uh
PS has also hired a stellar consultant
team and they're working closely with
the city to develop a master plan for
the surrounding nature preserve on on
Sunnyside. Um last but not least, I just
wanted to say uh it really has been a
privilege to work on this project. It's
truly an innovative and exemplary uh
public private partnership. uh the
preserve and the environmental center
are really intended to serve as
foundational community assets uh for
generations to come and that is uh
largely why this uh 99-year long-term
ground lease uh is being put in place.
Thank you,
>> Dr. Del. Thank you so so very much and
for highlighting all of those all the
pieces that it took to to get us to this
time. I know I am personally extremely
excited for this development on
Sunnyside, a long dormant um area in the
city. Um development has been difficult
to crack and I am appreciative that this
includes an element of preserving the
nature that exists there. Um and um I
will get to partake in a hike uh uh by
partners uh for environmental
stewardship next month. I look forward
to it maybe to be a little bit less hot.
That's why I chose September, but I'm
looking forward to getting to to see it.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you,
>> counselors. Any additional comments
>> from the public?
>> I'm so sorry. Before we do that, council
councelor Royo, I miss you when I look
that way.
>> No worries. Thank you, Council
President. Just wanted to make a
comment. I'm also very excited about
this project. I had a chance to partake
on the hike uh maybe a few weeks ago, a
month ago. um and uh was very excited
for someone who grew up um in the
southeast. I'd never stepped foot on
parts of that uh area to and there were
it was very hard to believe that was in
the middle of Lancaster City, especially
uh um and where we were. So, it was it's
very exciting to see what that's going
to be for future generations. So, very
excited about this.
>> Thank you. Any additional council
comments
from the public?
You might have to. Yeah, thank you.
>> Tony Dastra, 700 block of New Holland
Avenue. I am also looking forward to
this project. I think this is going to
be a good investment in the uh
environmental values our community is
starting to stand behind. Uh but I also
want to use this as an opportunity to
kind of speak to when investment comes
in one area, uh we do have to be mindful
of what occurs around it. There's going
to be a public hearing in September for
flexible residential development. at the
planning commission. I want to say the
date is September 17th. I forget right
now. Um but there's going to be a public
hearing about potential development
south of this site, I believe. And um
we need to be mindful of what occurs
after this facility goes up as a
community. And I do trust that uh
the stewards of this land are also going
to be mindful of that. But we also have
to make We are constantly looking at
ourselves and each other because this I
don't know I don't have a number for
this but I know a lot of money is going
into this project. I know that the
building is going to be net negative in
terms of producing carbon or at least
that's the vision which is a great
thing. Um but this might be some of the
biggest investment made in the community
since that part of town was redlined.
Um,
so the pendulum can very easily swing
and I would hate for this great project
to end up gentrifying the community that
surrounds it.
>> Good evening.
>> Good evening, Council Mayor Sarra. Thank
you, Chris, for the setup earlier. I'm
Diana Martin. I'm the executive director
of Partners for Environmental
Stewardship. I'm also a proud resident
of the city of Lancaster. It's one of
the reasons I'm really passionate about
this project. On behalf of our
organization, I want to thank you for
considering the ground lease agreement
tonight. This is a really exciting
milestone for this project and just
deeply grateful for the city's
partnership in making it possible. Over
the last 18 months, our team has worked
closely with city staff to discuss every
detail of the lease agreement. You've
probably read it. It's over a hundred
pages. We talked extensively about what
community engagement would look like on
this project, what it means to design a
worldclass green building for our
community, the programs that will run at
the center, and the ways that we'll
report back to you all and to the
community once we're open and operating.
Tonight's vote brings us one step closer
to realizing the vision outlined in the
city's 2023 comprehensive plan to
transform the northern portion of
Sunnyside Peninsula into the city's
first nature preserve and to build an
environmental center that reconnects our
community to the Konosoga River. Uh
Sunnyside has come up several times in
this conversation so far. To know
Sunnyside and to spend time there is to
fall in love with Sunnyside. Sunnyside
is just such a special part of our city.
It's shaped by the river. It's steeped
in history. There's so much uh
ecological potential. There's 89 unique
bird species we've identified out on
Sunny Side. Uh it's common to see uh
birds, bats, even foxes when you're out
there, deer. It's just such a special
place. And this project is really about
protecting that special place, restoring
its natural health, and creating
opportunities for our fellow residents
to explore, learn, and work right in
their own backyard. The environmental
center will serve as a hub for
environmental education, green job
training, and collaboration. We have
actually seven leading environmental
nonprofits who have signed on um to
either have offices there, lead
programming at the environmental center.
Um and the nature preserve will provide
space for trails, recreation, and
habitat restoration. Um so I want to
acknowledge the city's vision and
leadership in making this a true public
private partnership. Uh together, not
only are we expanding access to green
space, but also positioning Lancaster as
a leader in clean water, environmental
stewardship, and sustainable waterfront
development. So, on behalf of our board,
our partner organizations, and many
community supporters, um thank you for
your collaboration and trust and
commitment to this shared vision, and we
look forward to working alongside all of
you to bring this project to life. Um,
and anyone who's just hearing about it
today, I also invite you to be part of
the project. We're hosting public guided
hikes and tours, and I hope to get all
of you out there. I know that there's a
lot of passion in this room that we can
harness to make this happen. So,
appreciate you all being here tonight,
too.
>> Thank you.
>> Any additional comments from the public
on the resolution?
>> Hearing none, Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. M.
>> I.
>> Mr. Mr. Roy
>> I
>> Mr. Cle
>> Miss Craig
>> I
>> Miss Diaz
>> Mr. Hirs
>> I
>> President Be
>> I thank you so much.
>> Uh next resolution on our agenda is
resolution number 54 2025.
Mr. Harris,
>> a resolution of the city council of the
city of Lancaster approving a memorandum
of understanding between the Lancaster
County Conservation District and the
city of Lancaster authorizing the
appropriate officials of the city of
Lancaster to enter into such a
memorandum of understanding.
>> Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second. Uh this
is coming through public works.
Councelor Hirs.
>> Thank you, Council President. Uh this
resolution authorizes a routine update
to our uh memorandum of understanding
with the Langster County Conservation
District. The changes being made are
primarily administrative in nature,
including minor word changes uh and
allowing LCCD to provide documents
online and on its website. Kind of
coming into the first 21st century
there. um and decreases plan review and
permitting timelines for applications
for erosion and sediment control
programs from 10 calendar days to five
calendar days as well as an update to
the LCCD to reduce its inspection and
inspection response timelines from 10
calendar days to eight calendar days. Um
there are no changes to the municipal uh
responsibilities within theou. Um so it
does not change our responsibilities in
any way. Uh again, this is mostly um an
administrative update to our memorandum
of understanding with LCCD.
>> Thank you very much, Council Hersh.
Counselors, we heard from Director
Steven Campbell on this uh last evening,
and I just appreciate that we revisit
this from time to time, although we're
probably required to do to do that. I
appreciate that we do that to uh look
for efficiencies and I think the fact
that in 2025 we're finally allowing uh
the conservation district to uh have
electronic files and online access is uh
good and overdue. So, thank you for
that. Any additional comments from
council on the resolution
from the public on the resolution
hearing? None. Mr. Harris
>> Mr. Med
>> I
>> Mr. Royal
>> Mr. Glee
>> I
>> Miss Craig
>> Miss Diaz
>> I
>> Mr. Hirs
>> President B
>> I
>> and our next item on the administ on on
this part of the agenda is admiss uh
excuse me administration resolution
number 552025
Mr. Harris,
>> a resolution of the council of the city
of Lancaster approving an easement
agreement between the city of Lancaster
and the Lancaster Parking Authority
granting an easement to LPA for
encroachment into the public right away
over North Prince Street as more fully
set forth in the easement agreement.
Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> You have a motion and a second.
Councelor Craig.
>> Thank you, Council President. Um I'm
going to ask that Mr. Cohen come and
speak on this because my computer died
and my notes are in there.
>> Thank you, Council Craig. Yes, Mr. Cohen
will be available if there's any
additional questions. Uh councilors, uh
we heard a presentation last evening on
this easement agreement as it relates to
the um parking garage project on North
Prince Street and the former offices
that will be retrofitted into commercial
space and the projection easement that's
that's needed for above the sidewalk.
The clearances noted uh last evening
were over eight feet by the um architect
and the uh engineer for the project, I
believe, is who we heard from. Um, if
there are any additional council
comments uh or any additional questions,
Mr. Cohen is here and available.
>> Yeah, I think it might be worth
mentioning too that the building sat for
uh a long period of time over well close
to nine years and now it's being
revitalized to bring, you know, to add
some beautifification to the area.
>> That's right. And we also heard I have
in my notes from last evening that um
the parking authority does already have
a tenant although that those details
aren't being released out of respect for
wanting to ensure that they have the
space to make that announcement but so
thank you for that. Any additional
council comments on the resolution
from the public.
I'm assuming you're coming forward to
speak, so I'm going to give you a
minute. Okay.
>> Good evening.
>> Evening. Uh Tony Dash at 700 block New
Holland Avenue. Um, so I didn't realize
that the parking authority was on the
agenda at all when I was talking about
parking earlier. Um,
but I'm just I'm not opposed to this,
but I do think the city needs to take a
really hard look at how it's managing
parking and whether or not the parking
authority continues to provide it value
or more specifically provide the
residents the value that was um kind of
set up for. The idea was that we're
saving
because we're creating operational
efficiencies. But what we've also done
in in another sense is we've created an
entity which does parking management. I
know it has done outside of the typical
8 to six, but we have real residential
parking concerns that yeah, I want to
live in a carless society too, but
practically we need to move through the
society we're currently living in this
mess that has been made. And so,
especially now that the parking
authority is getting into other
ventures, which are good because we're
reusing space, and I hope that at some
point we're creating more affordable
business opportunities for people as
well throughout the city.
I think it's time for the city to
reassess its relationship to the parking
authority and really consider whether or
not it's providing the value to the
residents that it should be. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
Any additional comments from the public
on the resolution
>> hearing? None. Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. Med.
>> I.
>> Mr. Royal.
>> Mr. Gleas.
>> I.
>> Miss. Craig.
>> Miss.
>> Miss. Diaz.
>> I.
>> Mr. Hirsh.
>> President Baker.
>> I.
>> That concludes our legislative agenda
this evening. will take us to our next
item on the agenda, which is our second
public comment period. It's open to
comments on issues not previously on the
agenda. U duration of comments again is
limited to three minutes per speaker.
Please begin with your name and block of
residence for our meeting record.
>> Uh Brian Nelson, the 100 block of East
Lemon Street. And um I just want to say
that um I we live in a great community.
I love that we're getting that
environmental thing. That's amazing,
right? At the same time, we're getting a
data center.
How amazing is that? We're getting
something that preserves our environment
and we're destroying the environment at
the same time.
The priorities aren't there for me. I
don't I don't I don't see it. And Mayor
Sarra, I want to address you directly
here because you say you can't do
anything, right? But as Frank pointed
out, you were super super excited about
this building. So why didn't you do
anything then? Why didn't why have we
not tried to do you have plenty of ideas
here that you were given, right? And I
understand that we're we're held back by
red tape and I don't think that a data
center is truly an awful thing for the
community if done right. But the thing
is this was done with no public input
because it was labeled as a warehouse.
And I'm just struggling to try to figure
out where we go from here in terms of,
you know, making sure that this doesn't
happen again, right? And I know you guys
say that you're doing your reports and I
can't wait to hear them, right? I will
look at them and, you know, I will
reassess my position then. But um I
understand that the big bad bill is
probably going to hurt LGH. We're going
to get hurt, right? And we need to bring
new industry to Lancaster. I 100% agree
with that. Um I just don't think that
this is the way to do it. We're rushing
into it. We're we're just we see it as
dollar signs, but when in reality is not
going to bring the jobs that you think
it's going to bring. Um we need
technology. I I truly believe that the
tech industry is a major industry that
we can have here, right? A data center
sucks. I'm just going to put it right
out there. data centers destroy their
communities, right? And we talked about
potentially gentrifying a community,
which I hope we don't, right? And we
talked about that. But then we also
talked about potentially destroying
black and brown communities with data
centers. So where do they go? You're
going to kick them out and then you're
going to destroy where they're going to
end up going. I just I I'm struggling to
see the connect here, guys. Thank you.
>> Are there any additional speakers for
this period?
Please.
>> Good evening. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Frank Arolio, um, Old Trinity
Place. Um, I know I've been critical of
the administration with respect to the
data centers, but I believe in giving
credit where credit is due and in order
to be fair. Um, I sat through a
tremendously detailed presentation on
the five-year plan for Department of
Public Works um at the last council
meeting and I thought I understood that
it was the very first one that had been
prepared um I was very impressed with
the level of I wasn't impressed with the
visuals but I was very impressed with
the level of detail and the thought that
went into it. Uh, and if that was a
first attempt, uh, kudos to the
Department of Public Works. It was a it
was very well done. So, thank you.
>> Thank you, Mr. Kolio. And yes, it is
hard to make spreadsheets visibly
appealing, but they are interesting. Any
additional public comments for this
period?
>> Alexander King, uh, 600 block of North
Shippen. Um, so kind of to uh play off
Tony Dastra's comments, uh, I'd like to
say parking management in the city is an
unmitigated disaster. Uh, it seems to be
a sort of grassroots sort of thing,
which seems to be the dumbest way to
plan anything. Uh, I've lived in a lot
of cities in in Europe, in North
America, South America, and this is the
only city where you can petition to have
your block have parking restriction, and
the neighboring block doesn't. So on the
600 block of North Ship, there are no
parking restrictions. On the 500 block
of North Shippen. There are parking
restrictions. On the 700 block of North
Shippen, there are parking restrictions.
On the 200 block of East Newing
restrictions, not the 300 block. So,
what does this mean? This means that I
often see people living
on uh one of the uh larger apartment
buildings um on the corner of New and
North Ship and park in front of my
house, which is the perfect right to do
uh because there's no parking
restrictions there. And then later, you
know, I or my wife tries to come home
and we can't find anywhere to park
except for maybe three or four blocks
away on on Park Avenue, ironically. Uh,
and so I would like to see a just do
away with the parking restrictions and
then a plan set up. Uh, there is no
reason why there should be any parking
restrictions on the 700 block of our
ship. You know, there's no commercial
thing happening there. It's too far from
the hospital. The only thing is that the
residents of that street signed up to
have those parking restrictions so that
the renters on the uh large apartment
buildings on the corner of new or
shippen wouldn't be able to park in
front of their house. Uh whereas if
there were no parking restrictions in in
that neighborhood and there's a lot of
residential neighborhoods that have the
similar sort of hodge podge thing. So I
would like to see the parking authority
reexam.
>> Thank you. Any
additional speakers for this period?
>> Good evening. Good evening. My name is
Abby Haney. I live on the 600 block of
East Madison Street. Um I didn't come
here planning to speak. I just wanted to
listen. I know um I've been here talking
about the D centers before and we had so
many great people who showed up today to
continue to um advocate for action. And
so I really appreciate all of you who
came. Um I just had maybe one or two
things that I'm still kind of wondering
um from the last time that I was here.
Um one of them was the community benefit
agreement that I believe was mentioned
that would be um that would be figured
out between the city and Carissa Corwee.
Um I just have questions again about who
is the one who's going to do the um the
negotiating around that. Is it
unilaterally? is the community going to
be involved with that? Um because I
think we really should have the ability
to have a say. Um I also really I don't
know if he's here. Um but I also really
um appreciate Dan Wigel who came and he
had a whole list of things um that I
believe Lancaster Stands Up had um
drafted in a letter petition. Um and I
really think that those are great
actionable concrete steps that the
council can take. Um, full disclosure,
I'm here with Lancaster DSA and I really
appreciate the work that Lancaster
Stands up is doing in partnership with
us. Um, so I really, really hope that
you guys will take everything that's
been said today, take it in, um, and
really think about what the next steps
are going to be. Um, because it's clear
to me that the community doesn't want
this. Um, so we'd really like for you to
have some action. Thank you. Thank you.
There any additional speakers for this
period? Hearing
none, we'll close the second public
comment period this evening. Thank you
uh to all who spoke. The next item on
our agenda is the report of the mayor,
Mayor Sarra.
>> Uh thank you, council president. I I uh
want to just echo what we have heard at
the last couple council meetings and in
conversations that I've been having in
the community related to the data
centers. And just to reaffirm that we
hear your concerns about water
utilization, air quality, uh noise, um
the permitting the not the permitting
process itself, but the zoning
determination. Um and I am
working to be able to respond to the
questions and concerns, additional
questions that have been raised about
where that uh power is coming from. Um
and uh the entirety of like the
environmental impact and have begun to
have conversations about an
environmental impact report that would
address all of these things. I also just
want to be mindful of um uh again the
the questions about power and power
usage and electricity rates and
reliability of the grid are not things
that I'm going to be able to answer
because that is not in my wheelhouse.
Um, I have been trying to get those uh
questions answered and will continue to
try to get those questions answered uh
by other entities in Pennsylvania, most
especially PPL. Um, and I'm trying to
understand what I can about um how all
of that works.
Um, and so I'm going to stop with my
comments there. I just want to say I
hear you and um I believe that council
also hears you. I know that my our
administration, the people that are
working on your behalf every day hear
you and we are working to run down the
information that is needed uh to answer
the questions that have been raised not
only by the people in this room but by
others as well.
Um the second thing that I want to
mention is about residential parking
permits since that's been the topic of
conversation tonight to say that that is
really in the purview of the traffic
commission and the traffic commission um
engaged uh a a team to begin to address
residential parking across the city and
they are um having meetings um in our
neighborhoods to address residential
parking um in those communities. I agree
with you, Alex, that is crazy that um we
have these residential parking permit
blocks that some of them were approved
decades ago when there was a commercial
use and now there's no commercial use
and there's no way to like take them off
the rolls or to revisit that. That was
one of the things that was highlighted
in the in the recommendations that the
traffic commission I believe is working
to advance. So, there's a lot more
that's happening related to the
residential parking. It is a huge
challenge because there are more in the
city than the city was ever intended to
have. Um the third thing that I want to
take us back to is something that was
really great this morning with and this
is really um council to take you back to
when we um were able to um allocate $10
million to affordable housing. And this
morning I was able to attend a ribbon
cutting um for the Manor Street uh the
Manor Youth House um located on Manor
Street. As you might imagine um This
project will provide safe, stable
housing for up to nine young adults ages
18 to 25 who are homeless or
transitioning out of foster care or at
risk of homelessness. They will have
on-site support services um and uh and
this project is being led by community
basics as well as the valley youth house
which is a regional leader in youth
support services um to bring this
project to life. And I just thought you
should know that the investments that
council made um are coming to fruition.
I'm going to have more to say about the
ARPA housing investments um in the
coming weeks, but this morning was a
very sweet um event to participate in
and to see um that this is filling a
really critical need in our community
for young people who are aging out of
foster care. With that, I conclude my
report.
>> Thank you very much, Mayor Sarra. I
appreciate the update on the management
house. Um, these projects take a long
time. We make these investments. We did
so a couple years ago, so it's nice to
get the update and it's really
happening. Um, so I appreciate that. The
next item on the agenda is um report of
the president of council. I did speak
earlier and with back-to-back meetings,
I'm beginning to lose my voice. So, I'm
going to uh forego my report at this
time. Uh, we'll then take us to council
comment. So there any council comments
this evening? Councelor Amed.
>> Uh thank you council president and I do
want to thank all of the members of the
community who have come out and spoken
at the uh past several meetings. Um I
did request a report on uh the current
status of the data center and what
council's um options are moving forward.
Um and I do look forward to that report.
>> Thank you. That concludes my comments.
>> Thank you very much councelor. Any
additional council comments this
evening? Hearing
none. And having reached the conclusion
of our agenda, I'll hear a motion to
adjurnn.
>> Motion to adjurnn.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second. All in
favor?
>> I
>> We'rejourned. Thank you.